jake arrieta getting the start today
jake back in a cub uniform the black and
gold laundry brings out the best of them
he's been really good against the
pirates in his career he's been great in
this ball
parking thinking they might try to push
the envelope
now a little concern about keep ryan
hayes
they saw something they didn't like
during that at-bat when he fell
off the pitch brian hayes during his
follow through in a swing was shaking
off
his left hand
and a swing and a miss right there
[Applause]
jake gets the strikeout two away
bluff start by hayes and the ball hit
the other way by colin moran
moran lines a single to left putting
hayes at second
with two outs and a 3-2 pitch to kevin
newman
and a bouncer headed up the middle
and the pirates take a one-nothing lead
a slow bounding ball to center field and
kevin newman
scores hayes one-nothing pirates
that you know why he gets hits like that
is because the way he sprays the ball
around
there got him and arietta gets the punch
out
and that is that pirates though pick up
for run
now tyler anderson last season the 4-3
record for the
4-3 era
wow goes upstairs and gets bryant to
chase for the strikeout
got him throws it and arietta able to
get him one two
three
rip to left he had a base hit so baez
stayed back
and hammered that one squares one up
here to start the bottom of the second
breaking pitch from anderson and
keeps his nose right on it runner goes
pitches low stolen base
javi swipes the bag now the pitch
swung out of mist he struck him out he
rushed a fastball right by him
yeah he quick pitched him and uh what a
quick pitch it was
avi taking off for third swinging a miss
and a stolen base
[Applause]
robes being aggressive
two steals in the inning at al man at
third
and the cubs can tie this one up without
a hit
in the air and that's shallow towards
[Applause]
and it's 1-1 well it's all about javi
baez swiping a couple bases forces
didn't force derek shelton to move his
infield
in the air right center field fowler
long
run tracks it down marissa will tag from
third
and david bodie is giving the cubs the
lead it's 2-1
and anderson strikes out his mound
opponent but
they get a couple for arietta javier
baez and jake mariznick score 2-1
kick and pitch line caught and that's
going to be
a double play so with the shift on
bryant on the right side
and they turn it into two here is chris
bryant kb struck out swinging his first
time
that's hammered out to center fowler
back
back some more onto the track turning
and looking and it's gone
chris bryan will circle the bases and
it's 3-1
kb's first of the year well he hits him
high doesn't he yeah he sure does
you know it's a majestic powering home
runs
to the pole side this time at
straightaway center field
look at that the hesitation messed him
up nicely done
[Music]
and way out in front of another one
couldn't quite cue that one off
and there we go blowing straight out
here comes the o2 another
swing and a miss strike three two away
toward right looking up at short hops
the wall
so frazier headed toward third and the
throw there
he is going to be safe
thankfully with two outs and a
triple for frazier
here's the pitch swinging a weak tapper
up to third
gonzalez will go home the tag and he is
out contreras out at the plate
[Applause]
and there was a little bit of uh tie up
there because the bat was
right in the way and then anderson
worked his way out of it
getting bodhi and arietta and
yes he did and tyler anderson
nice when you look at his body of work
through five innings is impressive today
seven strikeouts trailing by two
outside corner got him
and moran left frozen
strikeout number five two seeing
fastball
really interesting his day with moran
went down and hayward at the plate
jason a single and he's also
reached on an error
that's some space that one is deep to
right
way back and out of here
that adds some space to it clear defense
by a
ton that was a star scraper
that was hayward's first cubs
extend the lane it is 4-1 second into
the day for jay hey
abby is the chance to add a run or two
right the runner at third
over there at first there's another two
for a base hit
why are you throwing him a strike i
think command is the issue
and i think the carl right now is a
little anxious and he's overthrown and
he really doesn't have a good feel for
where it's going
one two
corner ball game cubs win
[Applause]
5-1 the cubs
[Applause]
on the return of jake arrieta
get a nice effort from the veteran
and then kimbrough comes in and strikes
out the side to close it out